what do you think of that how can this
are you pretty convinced you're like
well it looks okay lads up with what my
tutor already told me and what does x'q
says so should be okay right
shouldn't not be okay you should not be
satisfied with that I totally didn't
hocus-pocus on you okay cuz even if I
got to some legit results do you how did
you pay attention to how many times I
fudged around during my do my
explanation right I was like well it
kind of looks like this and sort of
might go through there right I was
making up a lot of stuff okay
they talk about mathematical proofs
being rigorous right which is like it's
watertight there's nothing wrong with it
you can't poke any holes in it okay that
was yeah what's the opposite of water
time this is that was that's that is
hold everywhere okay so we need to do a
little better than this right this is
nice you can see the principles but we
need to be a little more rigorous okay
so step back how do we usually get
derivatives when you're starting off or
you try to meet a function for the first
time what's the first thing you do the
first thing you do is first principles
okay so let's give this a go
I'm gonna get rid of this graph how many
of you even remember how first principle
works I'll give you a clue
it starts with F - oh okay all right
help me out together we can do this
right what's the next thing right thing
yet before the end it's a little bit yes
why why is there a limit why is there a
limit because what I'm about to put down
here is a fraction what fraction is it
its rise over run your eyes on the rise
over run works when you've got this
point at that point and you I can't
agree between them but the whole point
of calculus is to not have two points
it's just have it at one point
hence limit okay all right so what is
this is just rise over but it's just so
much so you happen that two points
you're thinking about right how the
distance of H between them right and
when you look at these two Mike y94
image over here and FX is down here so
if you want to work out that distance
there there's your numerator it's just
right over on its y2 minus y1 on x2
minus x1 that's all it is just with
fancy me notation over okay so we try to
work out sine are we and we're trying to
show it in a kind of more rigorous way
so help me out
everywhere I saw Epps
I'll just put signs right you can cool
what can we do with this kind of options
do we have all I can do is expand really
by the way why would I do that
what is my goal in this situation I need
to somehow get rid of this edge or put
it into such a form such that I actually
can substitute here which I can't do
right now but I want to work toward that
okay so I'm not just doing mindless
algebra I have a golden room okay maybe
two five that's okay what's the
expansion sine H X cos H second what
could you do in there because we've just
done the expansion Wow what could I do
with this what kind of options do I have
remember my goal is to get rid of the
atrial and put in some form where I can
just evaluators I can certainly do some
factorizing here right the question is
what can I factorize well I've got these
two terms here that both have sine so
that's a start let's work with that okay
so I've got limit as H approaches zero
of put my side terms at the front right
what will I have
I'll have cars H for that one for this
one I'll have minus one okay you're my
caught on the fractures not finished yet
I know it's not finished yet but I've
seen this guy he will never work
together with this name okay because you
can't factorizing well you could you
could try to do this thing here okay but
I will save you some time to help you
tell you that you will not get very far
okay you might as well just leave it as
a closet a coz X okay but I'm gonna do
this I'm gonna separate out the limit
okay the limit of a sum is the sum of
the limits okay because this is calculus
with right so therefore I can stick this
guy okay now we factorize that side out
and we've got a cause here right these
are both in X now tell me what happens
to sine X sine X as H approaches zero
what happens to sine X answer nothing
happens to sine X because it has no H's
in it so H is doing its thing
approaching zero the sine X is like yeah
whatever they have you just carry on
okay so C has its independent of H right
I can actually bring it out the front
we're not used to doing that cuz you're
like it's going to vary room you can
just muck around with it it's like well
it has a variable but it's not the one
that I'm worried about
okay so it's independent so I'm gonna
bring it out the front so I'm gonna sine
X out here and then I have my limit as H
approaches zero of this time okay now
have the same thing happening here it's
the limit as H approaches zero sorry
I've mentioned by cos cos sorry take the
COS out then write the limit and then I
get this
what can I get that's that's with many
missing patients all right
no hmm look at this with me what what
kinds of conclusions can we draw about
this let's have a look at this Tepes
this you got cos h minus 1 over h h
minus 1 now what's happening - cause
it's happening - cause as h approaches 0
you know what cause looks like it looks
like this guy this cause ok now we used
to graph this in terms of X but I've got
H's so this H and this vertical graph is
constant H so as I'm approaching H
approaches 0 right from both sides I'm
going in here and here
and this is what I'm getting towards
what's happening I'm approaching one
time in fact I don't just approach it I
do get there ok so up on top here I have
1 1 minus 1 which is just 0 right hmm
what does that mean I've got 0 there but
what do I have on the denominator I also
see room but here's the important thing
okay I'm approaching 0 on the on the top
and I'm approaching 0 on the bottom ok
but they're approaching 0 in different
ways they're pretty very different just
like if I showed you did I said let's
graph this rational function looks like
nice to graph it and I could tell you
instantly it has an oblique asymptote
why because the pattern that it's hot is
bigger than the power of the bottom but
so what I'm thinking about oblique
asymptotes of horizontal asymptotes
they're about limits as X approaches
infinity right right and I would say
well what happens is it approaches
infinity but so does this they both
approach infinity don't think so
shouldn't they shouldn't it be like
infinity and that sounds like a
horizontal asymptote to me how can you
argue that it's an oblique asymptote
uh-huh okay so if both going toward the
same place but one goes faster right one
goes faster okay so now my question to
you is because H minus 1 and H they're
both going toward zero but which one is
going faster or are they going at the
same rate because those are two
alternatives either this guy's faster or
this guy's faster or they're equivalent
okay and that will tell you what kind of
thing you have now here's something you
can go ahead and draw it like hmm excuse
me and you will find this actually tends
toward zero okay it tends toward zero
what does that indicate to you which do
you think is going faster or rather
which do you think is going towards zero
faster
the bonus because if they're both going
towards zero right but this guy's going
faster right then this guy will keep on
being an actual number okay I want this
to be so said I know what the answer is
you can go you can actually know you can
do it if you're not satisfied with that
so you remember what a limit is right
it's just thinking about how something
behaves as you put in successive values
they get closer and question okay
now you actually because you have
calculators you don't have to guess what
happens to this okay you can actually
put batteries in you can see how bad
it'll be side I should say it's sine x
times zero okay now they're asking what
happens to this guy you have a similar
kind of scenario don't you don't you
sine H is going towards zero H is also
going toward zero right but which one is
going faster what are they going at the
same rate now have a look at sign now if
you go ahead and you actually draw this
properly to scale in radians and you put
y equals x on them okay and if you zoom
in here you're just gonna get they just
get closer and closer and closer
together right and they never actually
converge sorry diverge they never go
apart they're always going to order the
same ray
so therefore this guy is actually
approaching not zero but one they go
into the same place at the same rate
right just like saying you know if I did
this and I said well as X approaches
infinity they're both going to infinity
but they're going there at the same pace
so that's why the you get a horizontal
asymptote for that time so here I'm
gonna get this
okay because this limit is a pushing one
so this disappears and you end up with
this okay
how can bin study I'd like to say it's a
little better than what we did the first
time I think it's an improvement
okay because before I was just like
flopping around but my drawing was
actually pretty bad like it was not
symmetrical and I was just going to
being there with look okay right here at
least you've got some algebra to back
you up but where was the problem if
there was a problem it's all about these
limits isn't it these limits of the real
issue okay in order from here to here
and here to here
I actually resorted to the same thing I
did in the first place which I kind of I
said hey look at it you know and that
was the length of breadth of my argument
so can we do something a little better
than this it's called the squeeze you
like you like Pat really it's really
cool this feasible yet really okay going
going Ricky to squeeze Lord that's what
it's really close you'll see why it's
called the squeeze on a second it's a
brilliant name okay now just one quick
things see this graph of sine against X
I want to put one more thing on to it
keep you in mind
whoops that's not what I want over here
that uh at x equals PI on to right if I
graphed an X on there what's ten X as it
approaches X you can sue it's just
rising off to infinity okay so it's
doing this okay and just have a look at
that for a second okay
I've got ten I've got X and I've got
sign okay ten you just told me he's
writing and tries faster and faster and
faster and faster and faster
all the way up into the asymptotes in
fact it never even guess yesterday then
you got X how would you describe its
growth
it's constant I mean we could say it's
linear but that's sort of by definition
of linear it's class and it's just sort
of chugging along into a little rain
it's not getting any fire stock it's not
getting any slower
what about sign it's increasing we said
that they're being fired it slows down
eventually it runs out of steam is like
I'm so tired I'm gonna roll down this
trip and he loved making path or
whatever it is okay it's increasing but
Adams decreasing rate so therefore in
that domain for naught to cry on - I'd
like to suggest this inequality sign
poor guy he just runs out of steam he's
the lowest guy in this room okay X is
bigger than him and he's always bigger
than him in this domain right cuz as
soon as they're out of the game maybe
you could relate to this
there's your like you know slow and
steady wins the race guys train for the
city so he's just full side X the second
he starts right he's like I'm already
slowing down so sine X slow up beneath X
all-time and then there's that one guy
he's like ah I hate that guy
he 12 and he's still fit what's wrong
with him I don't care if he's the sports
captain whatever you know he's running
and he's just running faster and faster
faster
right he's like I'm just getting warmed
up guys you know so there you go this
Sunday I took mr. Knox or something he's
quite quick okay so I'm gonna say for
this domain this is always true you okay
with that reasonable I think you can do
me you can graph it graph it to scale
plot points prove to yourself I think
it's true now let me do something a bit
weird with this I'm trying to think
about this remember this guy
this was that issue before this guy is
hidden in here just not that obvious
okay I can put him in if I divide
everything by Sun watch
fight about everything my son 1 2 3 I
know you don't need used to dealing with
three inequalities but they follow
exactly the same rule is if you had to
go by this through I'll get one there
it's not about my son in the middle I'll
get X on sine X okay you're like wait
you wanted sign over sine x over X as
you see to me it doesn't matter all I
have on the right hand side of one cause
now I'm interested in what happens to
all of these things as I get closer to
zero remember that that was my fudge
right so I want to fix my fudge okay so
I'm going to take that that didn't come
out the way over today I'm gonna take
the limit as X approaches your you carry
that 1 2 3 this should all be true the
limit as X approaches 0 of this should
be less than the limit as X approaches 0
of this should be less than the limit as
X approaches zero okay you can take with
that just going across the board applied
limits so tell me how is studio twelves
what happens to one as X approaches zero
and said nothing he's just standing
there and like you just keep him using
yourself I'm just gonna stay what is
I'll leave this guy for a second
let's man what happens to what are the
cause now I actually know what happens
to cause as X approaches C or you told
me before it approaches one so therefore
the whole thing approaches 1 over 1
which is 1 and then of course we have
this kind of in milk now this is this is
you this is you the awkward
uncomfortable third wheeler on that date
like why do they agree to this
this guy is is greater than one but is
less than one as well he's being or do I
have to say it okay so what's going on
the squeeze law says if you have some
variable and you can show that it's it's
always between it's less than some value
and greater than some value at the same
time guess what you can say that it's
not between the values the only thing it
could be is that value okay you've been
squashed between them eventually it's
some awkward point you become that value
okay remember I'm thinking about a limit
by the way I'm thinking about a limit so
a better way to think about this is to
try and peer into what's happening here
right 10x and sine X you guys getting
faster and you guys getting slower now
let's reverse the time let's go back
towards zero what was happening at that
point everyone was running at the same
pace namely that now here's the reason
why by the way what's the reciprocal at
1 1 so if I take the reciprocal of the
right hand side I should be able to take
your typical of the left hand side also
so a corollary of this is is this this
is also true it is just as true as the
previous thing now I just as a as a side
note it's not the primary thing I was
interested in but I can play exactly the
same game here that I planted signed I
can play with Ted as well what would
happen if I divided everything through
by tan what would I get
what would I get on the Left divided
side by 10 divided by side my tan which
is the same as multiplying by Cobra just
cause you divide the middle by 10 you
will just get that and then you divide
the right-hand side and you get 1 you
take your limits now don't let's let's
let's skip this line here okay what's
the limit as X approaches 0
cause it's one what's the limit of one
it's one so you can squeeze this as well
which means you can squeeze this as well
they all approach one as you go closer
and closer to north okay they're
actually some semi-aquatic
results so now I've got this I have this
in the bag and this guy actually follows
from that okay how happy are you even
though does it feel a little more
watertight it should it is better I've
handled these but you should still feel
uncomfortable because I'm still pulling
the wool over your eyes does anyone did
anyone pay attention enough to notice
when I did it when did I do it you
should always be really suspicious when
I say let's just have a look at this and
you should be suspicious when I say are
you happy with that right because yeah
that's that's always been trying to be a
little shifty and saying there's
something going on here I'm just going
to ask you to accept it but not tell you
why okay so therefore what I really want
to go after is this this is the final
piece of the puzzle okay
it really there are no more there are no
more what do you think of this let's
consider okay if I can get that without
a shadow of a doubt then I can get to
here which can get me to here which can
get me to here which we did you get the
idea
all right sir are you ready what did
this topic start with again we started
trading what do I start again
oh we were doing tree I forgot sorry we
started by looking at radians right and
immediately we used radians to measure
what kind of shape circles because they
come from circle I've got a sensor I
also have a tangent here which means
that what kind of angle do I have
between the radius and attention all
right okay
I promise this will be anything now have
a look I want to compare three shapes
here three shapes and this time there's
no more what do you think just beyond a
show without but three shapes I've got
are this triangle in here let's call it
R a bar okay this sector and that big
triangle I draw
okay now let's just call this theta tell
me what's the area of the triangle
aha
what thank you sorry I should call this
s huh
it's just the tranquil just the
triangles cop R squared sine now do you
agree that triangle must be without a
shadow of a doubt smaller than the
sector that's sitting inside must be
because the sex is always gonna add that
little Center no matter how close they
get okay this is always going to be less
than the sector what's the area of the
sector
don't forget the angle is off R squared
just the center sir steps you used to
say feet up okay now do you agree that
that's it that we just talked about must
be small then we got a shadow it out
this triangle that goes outside the
circle no way it could be bigger than
that though so what's the area of this
triangle well I just need a home base
times height I know what the height is
what's fun like on this side now I've
got an angle and a side this is the
adjacent side and this is the office
sense right so this length should be if
I am calculating this on tennis okay cuz
tan X would be opposite moneychanger
okay so the area of that big huge
triangle is half R squared tan X ok
ready ready one
you're gonna say see that's like it's
like no guys I'm not the boy who cried
wolf it really is okay